un sistema de salud al borde del colapso
los hospitales de hong kong están
desbordados debido a la variante omicron
los enfermos deben esperar bajo el frío
invierno
no sabía que teníamos que esperar fuera
pensaba que estaríamos esperando dentro
del departamento de urgencias
estoy sintiendo fiebre fiebre y un poco
de fiebre y tuve un contacto cercano con
un paciente con kobe 19
el récord de infecciones en 24 horas fue
superado este jueves con 6 mil 116 casos
antes de la última ola el territorio
había registrado poco más de 12.000
contagios desde el comienzo de la
pandemia los expertos afirman que el
número diario podría aumentar a 28.000
en marzo pero los residentes de la isla
no creen que se puedan tomar las mismas
medidas que toma china continental creo
que las medidas de control de china
continental pueden no ser adecuadas para
hong kong las tasas de vacunación entre
los adultos de 70 a 79 años llegan al
43% la cifra de mayores de 80 que
optaron por vacunarse solo es del 26 por
ciento antes de la llegada de omicron
los pacientes serán tratados en salas de
aislamiento y los contactos cercanos
serán enviados a lugares de cuarentena
las escuelas los gimnasios los cines y
la mayoría de los lugares públicos están
cerrados y muchos empleados de oficina
trabajan desde casa en la burbuja de los
juegos olímpicos de beijing por el
contrario por primera vez desde el
comienzo de las competencias no se
registraron casos
en la vecina japón tras meses de
restricciones para los viajeros las
autoridades decidieron reducir los
controles fronterizos ante la baja de
casos y las críticas de empresas e
instituciones educativas el país ha
dejado de recibir 150.000 estudiantes
extranjeros debido a la pandemia además
de este alivio también se reducirá el
tiempo de 40 en obligatoria para los
viajeros a sólo 3 días